Speaker 1: . And part of protecting yourself means
protect yourself from the misinformation and of
course, the staggeringly stupid advice coming from
the right. Paul Gosar has become one of the latest
people on the right to actively
encourage people to fight back against
COVID protections. In a video that surfaced
this week put out there by Ethan Schmidt,
who runs the so-called anti-maskers club. So,
you know, right off the bat with the name there,
you can tell super serious organization. Got
a video of GOES-R and GOES-R said this? Hey,
here's to that anti-vaxxer group. Stay the course.
And then Schmidt replies, Yeah, anti-vaxxer club.
Stay the course. He's telling the
anti-vaxxers, the people who are
actively telling the rest of the country
to not get the vaccine. Stay the course.
Omicron is 73 percent of new cases across
the country, that graph is once again
making another swing. This is what the fifth
sixth wave of COVID we are now experiencing
in this Yahoo who serves in Congress.
Has a medical degree. Is telling people.
Listen to the anti-vaxxers, don't give up your
anti-vax ways, I mean, that's what stay the course
means. It means keep doing what you're doing, keep
spreading misinformation, Paul. Is that what you
want them to be doing? Because the statistics
also show that not only is COVID rising, but
it's rising faster in areas that voted for
Donald Trump, which means it's rising faster
among Republicans. We also know that far more
Republicans are unvaccinated than Democrats. To
put it another way, you're killing your base.
As I mentioned earlier on this week's program,
being a Republican is basically a co-morbidity
with COVID at this point. And their own lawmakers,
members of their own party are actively telling
them, keep it, keep it up, keep doing it. You're
killing them, you're actively killing them. Much
like Sarah Palin suggested, you know, at the
Turning Point USA conference, you know, oh, you
keep fighting back, we don't need the shot. I'll
get the shot over my dead body. Sarah Palin says.
Encouraging others to not do the bare minimum.
To protect themselves, and at some point,
if people like GOES-R and Palin, of course,
continue saying these things, we're going to have
to have a real conversation ahead of the midterms.
About what the mortality rate of COVID has done
to the American electorate. And I know that's
a rather morbid conversation that a lot of people
are avoiding, but but that's something we do have
to talk about. Because again, for months now, this
has been primarily a Republican centric disease.
Only about 10 percent of Democrats self-identified
Democrats say they're not vaccinated.
Almost 40 percent of Republicans say they're not.
And. We're almost seeing the same kind
of ratio in the death totals for COVID.
They're actively killing their base,
they're giving them this horrendous advice
that is killing them. So how is that going to
play out in the midterms? It is going to have an
impact. So again, that's a tough conversation,
it's certainly an unpleasant conversation,
but it's one that we're going to have to have
in the coming year, and maybe we need to have
the conversation sooner. Look, I'm obviously on
the left right. I have my politics on the left,
but that doesn't mean that I want to see anyone
on the right die from this virus. I don't want to
see any human being die from this virus again. If
I can stop it right now, if we had a magic wand,
I would do what I was in. I wouldn't hesitate.
Even, you know, we have to put the politics aside,
but. In order to do that. We have to be able
to convince the people on the other side
that they have to care about this, that
they have to take care of themselves. So
maybe it is time to have those conversations about
Republicans killing off their base and what that's
going to do to their election chances. Because I
guarantee you if they look at those voting rolls
and see that they've lost enough voters that
could have swung an election in previous years,
they're going to change their tune.
They're suddenly going to realize,
Oh, wait a minute. You know what? Maybe masks are
good. Maybe, maybe people ought to get vaccinated.
So it is time for those conversations, if for no
other reason than to scare Republican politicians
into finally doing the right thing and
encouraging their base to protect themselves.